3 students were asked about the PROBABILITY
of passing in their Mathematics
paper.
Let’s understand their responses.
The first student was very sad and said that
the probability of his passing was
LOW.
The second one was really happy because he
felt that the probability
of his passing is VERY HIGH.
The third kid was a little confused.
He says that his probability of passing is
somewhere in between.
So the probability just tells you HOW LIKELY
it is for an event to occur.
Here, the EVENT is passing the EXAM.
In the first case, the likelihood passing
is not very likely.
In this case,
the likelihood of passing is very likely.
And here, the likelihood of passing is
somewhere in between.
But none of them are sure, they are just telling
us what they feel and what is
the most likely outcome!
That’s probability.